welcome to drew's news summertime
edition
[Music]
your tasty new sandwich with a good news
pickle on the side
and with me at the desk is a man who
likes parm with his pickles
and it's delicious yeah yeah i do love
pickles and that's a big deal
i have to say i relish moments like this
well i was going to make a gherkin joke
but
i'll just move on on today's special
summertime
edition we're doubling down on food yes
there she is sammy stalls with their num
num yum yum
all right first up it's the perfect tick
tock trick for your barbecue
it's racked up over a million likes and
counting and
insider reports that it keeps your
fruits and veggies chilling while you're
grilling
check it out step one freeze an inch of
water in the bottom
of tray number one okay and then what
step two
assemble your favorites and veggies into
tray number two
okay delish step three put tray two
on top of tray one and voila so the tray
of veggie goes on top of the tray of ice
exactly it's like a ice tushy
and drew food experts say that that's
going to keep your your stuff cold for
hours and it's like you know not plugged
in you could do it at a barbecue it's
like
you know probably what the pilgrims used
to do i don't know you just
use ice to keep it cold by the way
um fruits and veggies i'm not so worried
about
try like fish yeah right i do have to
say at a barbecue i love a cold side
though because it's a hot day
you're having hot meat what's your cold
side
what i like hot meat um
my cold side i love a classic slaw
yup and a classic potato salad yeah i'm
not so much in a potato salad i just you
know how come well it turns out i'm
allergic to potatoes uh because they
make me fat
my body swells when i eat them so i love
coleslaw
i do i i do i love all sides i baked
beans
oh god i can get it with a baked bean
yeah what about a macaroni salad
i love macaroni salad
i could talk about macaroni salad all
day long salivating
well we have another round of food news
okay this is a food hack
and it's one that's gonna change your
smoothie game eat this not that
it says that the secret ingredient to
make your smoothie
super creamy is what hold on drumroll
cauliflower what in a smoothie now you
know a lot of people use
uh people bananas sometimes to make it
creamy
banana but experts say fresh or frozen
cauliflower not only sneaks in extra
servings of veggies it also lowers the
sugar
and it's great for folks who have kidney
issues that can't eat a lot of potassium
which is in bananas
uh-huh and i've made cauliflower crust
pizza i put cauliflower in like chili to
thicken it sometimes i've done
just like half chili or half meat half
cauliflower
makes sense it makes so much sense that
i feel
like you need to do that on the show at
any time
but now they're putting cauliflower in
smoothies we have one here
i don't know i can see how it's going to
work because the cauliflower is just
going to kind of disappear
but i mean by the way feel how cold this
is burr
oh my gosh it's super refreshing okay i
haven't tasted this yet we're going to
do this ready one two three
hmm what
do you even taste any cauliflower in
there
okay drew's busy
it tastes like ice cream like a
milkshake it tastes like a milkshake
that's exactly like a malt
yes whatever it is i'd like the uh
recipe please cauli malts
cauli molly golly molly um
by the way i'm not kidding this is like
phenomenal we have to put this recipe on
i don't understand it but i want it i i
never want it to end
i don't know how it's good for me though
is it weird that we just trust and we
just
like start drinking well whatever it is
it'll be on our website it is like
seriously one of the best smoothies i've
ever had in my life all right well thank
you for watching this summertime edition
of drew's news and we can't wait to see
you
soon and until then may your fruits be
cold and your smoothies be smooth
that's sweet that was in the prompter
but i do stand by it
and take all the good energy with you
[Music]